Okay.
No,
I think it's easy to create a straw man
to attack game theory.
Uh,
and if you literally think that the
payoffs are you written down are
completely right,
uh,
and that the other play and all the
players are identical,
uh,
you will come up with a really stupid
answer.
Uh,
that is,
uh,
this leading,
and that I think is a,
uh,
is a poor application of gain through.
And that's also why we call the book the
Rd strategy.
Uh,
there is a science behind it,
but sometimes it's used,
uses a dialogue.
It's providing a common language so that
we understand the reason why we think
somebody is going to take this strategy
is because they see all of these
different options playing out in this
way.
Do you agree with that?
Where is our,
our conclusion falls from our
assumptions.
So now we can understand,
do we have a common set of assumptions?
But this article pointed out something
else that I think is even more
important,
that there's multiple levels of game
theory.
And I like to think of us as metagame
theorists,
uh,
or it's not just about solving a
particular game.
It's about making sure you're playing
the right game.
And so,
uh,
now how do you go about designing a
game?
And you could think about that.
You can change the rules of the game.
You can change the players in the game,
you can change the payoffs in the game.
You can link one game to another game.
So you need to understand some game
theory to figure out when I'm doing my
game design,
are these changes likely to help me or
likely to hurt me?
And I think in the end,
I'm not going to be so precise to say
it's going to be 7.36,
5% improvement,
but it's a good idea to link these two
negotiations.
What isn't a good idea to link these two
negotiations?
And that's the level at which I think we
can be
very helpful.